So we have threads at the user level, we have threads at the kernel level.
We will now see what are some of the interactions that are necessary in
order to efficiently manage threads.
Consider we have a multithreaded process.
And let's say that process has four user-level threads.
However, the process is such that, at any given point of time,
the actual level of concurrency is just two.
Basically, if you look at the process,
it always happens that two of its user-level threads are waiting on I/O, and
then some other two are actually executing.
So, if our operating system has a limit on the number of kernel threads that it
can support, it would be nice if the user-level process actually said,
I just really need two threads.
So when the process starts, the kernel will first give it, let's say, a default
number of kernel-level threads and the accompanying lightweight threads.
And let's say that is one.
Then the process will request additional kernel-level threads, and the way it's
done is that the kernel now supports a system call called set_concurrency.
In response to this system call the kernel will create additional threads and
it will allocate those to this process.
Now let's consider this scenario in which the two user-level threads that were
mapped on the underlying kernel-level threads block.
They needed to perform some I/O operation and then they were basically
moved on the wait queue that's associated with that particular I/O event.
So the kernel level threads are blocked as well.
Now let's say we have a situation in which the two user-level threads that
were running on kernel level threads issued an I/O request, and
now have to wait for that to complete.
So it's a blocking I/O.
What that means is that the kernel-level threads themselves,
they're also blocked on that I/O operation.
They're waiting in a queue somewhere in the kernel for that I/O event to occur.
Now we have a situation where the process as a whole is blocked,
because it only had two kernel-level threads, both of them are blocked, and
there are user-level threads that are ready to run and make progress.
The reason why this is happening is because the user-level library doesn't know
what is happening in the kernel,
it doesn't know that the kernel threads are about to block.
What would have really been useful is if the kernel had
notified the user-level library before it blocks the kernel-level threads.
And then the user-level library can look at its run queue,
it can see that it has multiple runnable user-level threads, and,
in response, can let the kernel know, so, call a system call
to request more kernel-level threads or lightweight processes.
Now in response to this call, the kernel can allocate an extra
kernel-level thread, and the library can start scheduling the remaining
user-level threads onto the associated lightweight process.
At a later time when the I/O operation completes, at some point the kernel will
notice that one of the kernel-level threads is pretty much constantly idle,
because we said that that's the natural state of this particular application.
So maybe the kernel can tell the kernel-level library that, you no
longer have access to this kernel-level thread, so you can't schedule on it.
By going through these examples you realize that
both the user-level library doesn't know what's happening in the kernel, but
also the kernel doesn't know what's happening at the user level.
Both of these fact cause for some problems.
To correct for these issues, we saw how in the Solaris threading implementation,
they introduced certain system calls and special signals that
can be used to pass or request certain things among these two layers.
And basically this is how the kernel-level and
the user-level thread management interact and coordinate.